الاغتيالات او محاولات قتل المؤيدين للحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا تعود من جديد الى
روسيا وغالبا ما تكون اوكرانيا المتهمه
الاستهداف الثالث كان من نصيب الكاتب
والسياسي القومي الروسي البارز زخار الذي
اصيب في مدينه
بغرب روسيا بتفجير عبوه ناسفه قتل جراءها
سائق السياسي الروسي الخارجيه الروسيه
وصفت الحادث بالعمل الارهابي فيما احتجزت
سلطات الروسيه رجلا قالت انه اعترف بتنفيذ
الهجوم بامر من المخابرات الاوكرانيه على
طريق كان يسلكه الرجل قبل ذلك وتحديدا في
الثاني من الشهر الماضي قتل المدون
العسكري مكسيم فوبيين في تفجير تمثال مفخ
اهدي له في مقهى بمدينه اثناء فعاليه كان
يحضرها هناك السلطات اوقفت امراه روسيه
اقرت بانها قدمت الى الضحيه التمثال الذي
سبب ايضا في اصابه 30 شخصا لكن حينها
اتهمت موسكو انصار المعارض الروسي المسجون
اليكس سنفالني الاستهداف الاول منذ بدء
الحرب في اوكرانيا وقع العام الماضي عندما
قتلت داريا دوجينا ابنه العالم السياسي
الروسي وشخصيه العامه
في ضواحي موسكو في العشرين من اغسطس حينها
قال الخبراء خبراء في الشان الروسي قالوا
ان المستهدف من وراء الهجوم والدها رغم
تاكيدهم على ان عملها الصحفي ونشاطها
السياسي تجعلها مستهدفه بشكل اكبر منه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات